one you take probably you have to take  on D5 but  yeah because I think Knight A4 Rook A1  just loses right yeah 94 2K1 followed by  Knights at least looks very scary yeah  it might not lose immediately but  definitely not what would you want to do  yeah and the other option is to grab on  D5 which yeah no marvelous goes Knight  takes four Evolution bar screams that  this is losing Knight B7 Knight B7  that's it that's it and he resigns  oh my god oh what a way to end the game  yeah it's of course a big relief for  yanya that it's immediately over sees  the match with Knight B7  nice little trick there at the End by  Yan everybody's focused on 96 I'm  actually wondering if that one as well  but  Carlson not finding the options not  finding the chances excellent job here  by Jana pomichi from what looked like it  might be a scary situation into full  control  yeah let's just show that what what's  happened